Welcome to the GDPs seminar. Everyone.
Before we introduce our invited speaker,
let's go over some rules and logistics. First
of all, please mute yourself during the talk,
but if you have questions, you can unmute and
ask questions, or use chat room to post your
questions so that we can address them in Q and A
session at the end. Second, today's GDP seminar is
open to external, external audiences, therefore no
classified discussion is allowed. So please watch
out. And finally, the talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in our YouTube channel. That's about
it. Now. Let me briefly introduce our speaker
today. It is an honor to host Elizabeth Quinn,
who is an assistant professor at Georgia
Tech, jointly appointed in the School of
Aerospace Engineering and the School of
computational science and engineering.
Her interdisciplinary research develops new
computational methods to enable engineering
design and decision making for complex systems
with special expertise in model reduction,
scientific machine learning and multi fidelity
methods. Recent awards include a 2024 ao force
Young Investigator Award and the 2023 Hans Fisher
visiting fellowship at the Technical University of
Munich. Prior to joining Georgia Tech, she was a
Von Karman instructor at Caltech in the department
of computing and Mathematical Sciences. She
earned her SB, SM and PhD degrees from MIT today,
Elizabeth will talk about multi fidelity, linear
regression for scientific machine learning
from scarce data. I'm sure she's going to give a
wonderful talk. So please have a high expectation.
But before I pass the button to Elizabeth, let me
ask one question, I happen to know that the you,
the one sport you regularly do, like once a week,
is the rock climbing. I'm sure a lot of people are
already familiar with with rock climbing among the
audiences, but some are not. So if you can briefly
introduce why you are so into the rock climbing,
and, you know, advertise rock climbing to them,
oh goodness, okay. Well, if you haven't
tried rock climbing, it is an Olympic sport,
and the men's and women's Olympic
events are going to be next week,
I think so you should look up the schedule
and watch because it's pretty cool to watch.
And that will also be my pitch for why
you should do it, because I think it's,
it's a nice sport for for watching, because when
you go to the gym, you can, you can try to climb,
and then when you are tired and don't feel
like actively climbing yourself, it can be
pretty fun to watch other people like try to
do the climbs. So I think it's a nice pastime.
Nice. You can utilize your
time in maximum enjoyment. Yes,
awesome. Okay, well, floor
is yours. Elizabeth, all
right. So yeah, thank you for the invitation
young soo to speak in the seminar, and I'm
very pleased today to present some recent work
that has been submitted. Came back from review,
and we've resubmitted the revision, so fingers
crossed that it will be accepted for publication.
And so this is joint work with honor ban Choudary,
who is a research scientist at UT Austin,
and with my student day, young Kang at Georgia
Tech, and his student, Vignesh cell at UT,
Austin. So before I start, I want to say that I
typically like to take questions throughout the
talk, so I will try to pause in a couple places
to see if there are questions. And I'll also
ask Yang su to help me monitor the chat and just
interrupt if there's, like, a clarifying question.
I just think talks work better if I can address
things along the way, rather than saying saving
everything to the end. And I've, you know, planned
the talk so that there should be time for that,
right? So the motivation for this work, as well
as most of my work, is to support decision making
in engineering and science. And when we think
about the decisions that we might want to make,
a lot of times, they rely on what I will call a
many query computation. So that includes things
like optimization, uncertainty quantification
and control tasks. So in optimization,
you might have to query a model at every step of
a gradient based iterative method. In uncertainty
quantification, you would be querying a model
for every sample of say, like a Monte Carlo,
like uncertainty quantification, computation
and in control computations, you're querying
the model. Basically you know at every second
say in real time to understand, like, what the
next control input should be. So traditional
numerical simulations that comprise. Most of
our traditional models are based on physics.
They're often high dimensional because they
result from discretizing a continuous governing
equation on a high dimensional computational mesh,
and that makes them generally too expensive for
this many query setting. So these, you know,
you're not going to be solving these traditional
high dimensional simulations, you know, in real
time, say, for control, or you can't afford to do
that many samples in uncertainty quantification.
So there's a real need for efficient, you know.
And when I say efficient, I'm thinking like fast,
so computationally efficient and cheap surrogate
models to enable decision making. So I think
everybody would probably agree that there's been
a lot of interest in machine learning methods,
for surrogate modeling, for engineering systems,
they've shown a lot of promise, partially through
some very visible successes in other domains that
were traditionally seen as extremely challenging,
so in computer vision and natural language
processing, and, say, playing, playing the
game of Go. So they've seen some real practical
successes. And in addition to those practical
successes, there are some theoretical guarantees
of of what I call the expressive power of these,
of these machine learning models. So I'm thinking
in particular about neural networks, for which
there are a lot of theoretical guarantees that,
say, like, there is a neural network of some
shape and size and form with some parameters that
can match, like, you know, sort of any complex
nonlinear function, like, perfectly, essentially.
But there's a significant gap between that theory
and engineering practice, and that's because
of, like, basically what I was saying, like,
there is a neural network that can match things
perfectly. It's just we don't know a lot about
like, what the neural network is like, what its
architecture is, what its parameters should be.
And so because there's that gap between the theory
and the practice, there's a real lack of trust,
I think, for using these machine learned
models for engineering design, where you have
some consequences, that impact, that have, like,
you know, high costs, both in terms of dollars,
but also in terms of, like, potentially human
safety. And so that's a significant barrier
to the widespread adoption of machine learning
type methods in engineering. So to address that,
one might ask, what is the reason that we have
trust in traditional numerical simulations? And
I would say that some of the reasons for trust in
traditional numerical simulations are that they're
based in physics, which is something that we sort
of understand to be true. So there's a strong
foundation. Additionally, we make some really
explicit and transparent modeling assumptions
in physics based simulations. So for example,
like, if you're going to simulate a fluid flow
with Euler versus Navier Stokes, like, you
know that you're making an assumption in Euler
equations that, like, the viscous effects are
negligible. And that helps you understand both
when to trust the simulations as well as when
we don't. And in addition, we have, you know,
many decades of numerical analysis that help us
understand the errors in these discretized these,
like, sort of discretized PDE models. So
then we ask, okay, so in machine learning
or in statistical learning, like, where do we
get trust from? And I would in sort of many of
these applications. Trust comes from big data,
like the idea that you have so much data that,
like, you've kind of, like seen everything
there is to see, and you can really represent,
like that reality quite accurately. Okay, so to
be more mathematically specific about what that
trust means. I'm going to say, Okay, we're going
to consider an input random variable z and an
output random variable y1 and y1 is some function
f1 of z. And in the setting that I'm considering,
I really think of f1 as being an expensive
computational model, although you could
think of it as also perhaps being a physical
experiment, but like, let's just think of it
as a expensive computational model. So maybe this
is something you'd run on a supercomputer to get,
like, the output y of z. And so the surrogate
modeling problem from data is then to say, Okay,
let's suppose that f hat is a parameterized
model with parameters beta. And so I can
choose some parameters beta, and then I have some
input, and then I can give it my input variable,
Z, and it will predict outputs. So the machine
learning task is then to find the best parameters
of that model. So I want to find the beta star
that minimize you know this is a standard loss.
So this is the in this case, we're minimizing the
square of the error of the surrogate model. And
notice like we have an expectation here. So that's
sort of like over the joint distribution of the
input and output data. And because often we cannot
easily compute these expectations exactly the
standard. Third thing then is to approximate this
from from data. So now I suppose I have input and
output pairs, so like I have capital N of them.
And so then I've got z i as being the inputs,
and then y is being the outputs. And so then I,
instead of minimizing the exact expectations,
will try to find the beta that minimize the
empirical mean square error. So this setup,
I think is, has become quite widespread and maybe
familiar. All right, so this is the problem that
is being solved in machine learning, generally and
essentially. When I say trust comes from big data,
mathematically, we're saying, if that n is
large enough, then this empirical mean square
error minimization well approximates this true
mean square error minimization. And so if n is
large enough, then we trust that the training
performance is going to be representative
of what we call the test performance. So you
know how we would do on data that's not in on
inputs that are not in this training set, but
in engineering settings, and is often small
because each because each of these, why I one data
points comes from evaluating that expensive model,
and so we're often pretty far from the setting
in which we might say, like one could implicitly
trust that minimizing this error is representative
minimizing that error overall. And so the main
idea of today's talk is to address that lack of
trust due to small to small, n or scarce data by
combining our limited, expensive, high fidelity
data with some greater volumes of cheaper,
low fidelity data, in order to address the
small Data Challenge, and when I say small day,
I'm really talking about that small high fidelity
data. And so what I'm going to present today is a
new method for multi fidelity linear regression.
So acknowledging that linear regression models are
not as general as the neural networks that I was
motivating the talk with, but seeing this as kind
of a step towards more general machine learning
models, and in that linear regression setting,
we're going to develop a new method that's based
on multi fidelity control variants. I'll explain
what those are. I'll present some bias and
variance analysis that help us understand the
accuracy and robustness of the of the models that
we learn from the multi fidelity data. And then I
have some numerical results that demonstrate the
sort of potential for this multi fidelity method
to really address these small data training
challenges. So I will pause right here and
just see if there were any questions so far about
like the notation, the setup, or anything else.
I don't see questions in chat yet. Yeah.
Yeah. It's a pedagogical technique I've learned
to give a long pause in case
people formulate questions.
Okay, well, then I will jump right into the
first part of the talk. Okay, so I'm going
to talk about multi fidelity control variant
methods. So control variants are a technique,
or, you know, a family of methods, that actually
arise from Monte Carlo estimation of, you know,
statistics. And the goal is to reduce the
variance of Monte Carlo estimators. So I'm
going to set aside the machine learning problem
for now, and just think about like a standard
Monte Carlo estimate of like the output mean.
So if I wanted to estimate the mean of f1, of
my random variable z, and I had n samples of the
input z, I then I could have standard Monte Carlo
estimators just the sample mean of the outputs.
And we know that this estimator is unbiased,
so that the expectation of this estimator
is the expectation of the is the true mean,
and that the variance scales with one over n. And
so if n is large, then you know this variance is
quite small. And so we think that the estimator,
we would say, the estimator, has a low standard
error. And then if n is very small, then the
this variance could be quite large. And so this,
this estimator could have quite a high standard
error. So the goal of control variance is to
reduce the variance of the estimator. And
the way we do that is we introduce, like,
another random variable. So like, let's just, I'll
tell you what it is in a second. But like, suppose
that we have another random variable, W and it's
correlated with the outputs. So it's, you know,
maybe think of it as an approximations as well,
correlated with the outputs. But and suppose,
for now that we know what the mean of that random
variable is, so we like have some exact expression
for the mean of w, then this formula defines the
control variable estimator. So we've got mu hat
and I use CV to say this. The control variable
estimate. And so we have this, this first term,
which is kind of the standard, original
estimator, and then we add a second term which
is a correction. And that correction is basically
the true mean minus the sample mean of of the w's.
Okay. And so the key here is that these W, I's
are correlated with these f1 of Z eyes. Okay,
so this estimator has some nice properties. The
first one is that this control very estimator
does not introduce bias, and that's because in
expectation, like the expectation of W is mu,
W, right? So, so that term just goes away in
expectation. So that's nice. And alpha, I should
say, is some kind of scaling coefficient. I'll
talk about it more later, but just think of it as
a constant for now. The second property, I guess,
that we want to analyze is the variance of this,
of this control, very estimator, which is related
to the standard error of the estimator. And so I
can, I can, you know, give an expression for the
variance of the estimator just by expanding the
sort of covariance, definition of variance. And
this is what I get in terms of alpha. So you see,
there's, you know, kind of, here's
the variance of the first term, like,
here's the variance of the second term. And then
here's kind of the sort of cross that cross term,
and you can minimize this expression with respect
to alpha and find an alpha star which minimizes
the overall variance of this estimator. And
that alpha star is basically is given by this
expression. So it's the covariance of the model
with with your W, and divided by the variance of
w. So if I now stick that alpha star in into
this expression, this is what I get. Okay? So
with the optimal alpha star, you'll see that the
variance of the control variant estimator is the
variance of the original Monte Carlo estimator
minus something positive or non negative. And
so essentially, the takeaway is that the
higher the correlation between f1 and W,
the greater the variance reduction. And
that makes, I think, some intuitive sense.
Elizabeth, yeah, those are some questions. Do you
want to take it all right? The first question is
from Kevin, do we need to know the exact mean
and the same samples are, yeah? Are used for w,
yeah? So we will end up estimating the mean of W.
In fact, I just introduced it with the exact mean,
just to get the idea across, and I will talk a
little bit more about the number of samples of w,
but yeah, I'm introducing it with the same
number of samples here because it's just a
bit simpler to not have to have a lot
of different letters running around.
But we can relax that it can be kind of
there are different sampling strategies.
All right, sure. And the second
question from Duchenne is asking,
Are you ignoring? The intercept term in the
linear regression in the general form is,
y is equal to mx plus c. I see you
used y is equal to mx function.
In my numerical experiments, I do indeed have an
intercept so we allow kind of a constant like,
you know, one of the columns of the columns of
the linear regression matrix is a bunch of ones,
although I don't, I don't remember having
that on a slide yet. Honestly, thank you
for the questions. All right. So, yeah. So this
is the main idea of control variance. Basically,
the higher the correlation between w and f1 of z,
you know, the greater your variance reduction. And
so multi fidelity control variant methods are
based on this idea where we use lower fidelity
models to define that w. And so now I'm going to
say, suppose I have some function f2 so you think
of this as maybe a coarser grid than f1 or maybe,
you know, some simplifying assumptions are made
relative to f1 so that this runs faster. Then
this is the way I define the approximate control
variant. And so to Kevin's question, like, notice
here now I have replaced the exact mean with a
sample mean, and what I'm showing you is, is
really the sampling strategy that's based on what,
like some people would say is them, is the multi
fidelity, Monte Carlo method. And then there's
kind of variants of this, where you can have, you
know, different different numbers of samples for
each of these things. But basically I'm saying
that f2 is cheap, so I can afford many more
samples of f2 than I can of f1 so this is kind of
a high sample approximation of the mean of f2 so
this, instead of knowing the mean of W exactly,
I'm approximating it with up a lot of samples,
and I can easily generalize this to many other
low fidelity models just by adding. You know,
additional terms. So for like the f3 term, you'd
have something like this. For the f4 term, you'd
have something like this. And there are several
variations on this theme. So then what I'm using
in this talk is from this multi fidelity Monte
Carlo paper, which is a 2016 paper by Benjamin per
and collaborators, but Alex Gorodetsky at Michigan
has done a lot of work to generalize that. And so
that would be this work would would really kind
of allow n and m here to really vary in in more
general ways. And another variant is, is known
as ml blue, or multi level best linear unbiased
estimators by Daniel Schad and Elizabeth Ulman,
and that would allow sort of even more general
structures, like you would have sort of different
model groupings, just to give you a flavor of what
exists. But these latter two are a little bit
more complicated, I think, just in terms of the
notation in particular. So I'm sticking with multi
fidelity Monte Carlos to introduce the main idea.
Okay, so, so I've introduced the main
control area idea, and I'm saying if I'm
using low fidelity models to define the control
variants. And so those low fidelity models are
being used to generate correlated samples
are going to help me reduce the variance
of my Monte Carlo estimator. That's kind
of the punch line. Are there questions i
All right. So, yeah,
this is just kind of highlighting, again, what
I was saying. So this is n expensive samples,
and n is not very large from the high fidelity
model, and now I have lots of cheaper samples from
the low fidelity model that are used to compute
this correction in this 2016 paper, Benjamin per
Strafford shows that, like, the multi fidelity
Monte Carlo estimator has lower variance than
the Monte Carlo estimator of equivalent cost. So,
like, there's kind of a constraint there saying,
like, Okay, I'm trading off some of my high
fidelity samples to get low fidelity samples
under certain technical conditions, which I will
summarize here by saying if the high and low
fidelity models are sufficiently well correlated,
and if the ratio of costs between models is
sufficiently high, and the detailed conditions are
in that 2016 paper. Additionally, in that paper,
they look at the influence of what you might think
of as hyper parameters of the methods. So like you
know, what's the best alpha, what are the best m
and n in this sampling structure? And essentially,
you can formulate an optimization problem to say,
like, what is the alpha n and m that minimize the
variance of the mfmc estimator? And there's
an analytical solution to that problem. And
the analytical solution then depends on second
order statistics of the models. So sigma being
the standard deviation of f1 and f2 and rho
being the Pearson correlation coefficient,
so the second order correlation coefficient,
because in many settings, those statistics are
not exactly known. The standard practice then
is to use a small number of pilot samples to
estimate those statistics, and then you get an
estimate of the optimal alpha, n and m that you
would then use to figure out the number of like
the n, m and alpha. To implement this estimator,
I see a question, Do I understand correctly? One
needs M plus M samples of f2 in multifidelity
Monte Carlo. Actually, these are nested
samples, so it's m total, and then these
n are the first n of those M but in some of
the general variants that I mentioned, things
are a little bit different. But yeah, you need
a lot more samples of f2 than of f1 in general.
All right, so that's the sort of background on
multi fidelity Monte Carlo. And so what I want
to explain now is how we use this for multi
fidelity linear regression. So back to our
linear regression problem. I have the input
random variable z, output random variable y1
and where y1 is related to z through this high
fidelity model, which is expensive. So now I
restrict to this linear regression setting. So
I'm going to say, let X denote features of the
input. Okay. And so this is where, like, I could
have a constant feature to allow an intercept,
right and, you know, so x could be like polynomial
features. They could be Fourier features. They
could be features, you know, chosen from some
physics informed library. But whatever they are,
I'm going to have a linear combination of
those features determine my output. So this is
my model class. So. Beta are my linear regression
coefficients and so now just just going back one,
okay, so this is my linear regression task
basically minimize this expected error. All right,
so this linear regression problem was very
well understood. So its solution is given by
this formula. So just the expectation of xx,
transpose, inverse, times the expectation of
x times y. So just note, this is a square matrix
and this is a vector. So I'm going to just note
those expectations by c, x x and c x y, because,
like, this is a covariance matrix, and this is,
in sense, like the covariance of the inputs
with the output. And just remind folks that if
x and y are centered, so if they have mean zero,
then these are these covariances, and then the
optimal beta star satisfies this interpretation
of the residual of the model being orthogonal to
the features. So the standard way we approximate
this solution, because, you know, this obviously
has expect, exact expectations, is to say, Okay.
Now, given data pairs, you know, n data pairs of
inputs and outputs, I will then approximate these
covariance matrices with the sample. So these are
sample covariances, and then my beta hat or
beta tilde, and I forget what I used, oops,
sorry. Okay, then my approximation is, is just
given by, like, inverting the sample covariance,
multiplying it by this other sample covariance.
Okay, so that's standard, but I'm actually not
going to use the standard approximation. And the
main reason for that is that this is actually not
an unbiased estimator of beta star. And that's
because c x x n here is unbiased for estimating c
x x but then once you invert it like the inverse
of the unbiased estimator is not an unbiased
estimator for the inverse, and for reasons that
will become clear, I care very much about it
being unbiased, so I'm going to do a modified
approximation of a linear regression solution,
where instead I'm just going to assume that I have
CXX Exactly. The justification for that is to say,
well, the expensive part of getting data is really
getting y1 right, like every output requires that
I evaluate this expensive model. But in theory, I
could get lots of inputs for free, and basically
have so many input samples that I could assume
that I have a very good or exact estimator of c,
x, x, because that only depends on the features
and not on the output of the model. And the
other main reason, like I said, is because
this is now unbiased. This beta has unbiased
estimated for beta star, and that's going to be
important for us in in our multi fidelity model.
Any questions about this setup, I
so I'll ask if f1 and f2 have to share
an input domain. Yes, like so far,
we've just kind of assumed that they have the
same inputs. If they don't have the same inputs,
you'll need to do more research. But that is an
interesting case that, of course, we're aware of
and thinking about how to handle. Yeah. Okay,
so that's the high fidelity linear regression
setup. And so having chosen the parameters using
that n high fidelity data estimator. We define a
trained model using those those parameters. And
now, if I think about for a given input, z like,
what is the variance of the model predictions,
so f hat like, the variance depending on what
that data are, then, in fact, that variance can be
related to the covariance of these beta hat n's,
so of those parameter estimates, which is what
this says. So the variance in model predictions
comes from variance in the parameter estimates,
and the variance in parameter estimates comes from
variance in these like C x y estimates. And so if
we have a small n, we would have high variance in
the CX y estimates, and therefore high variance
in these beta n estimates, and therefore high
variance in the learned model predictions. And
so that really kind of kills your robustness,
like thinking like training on this small data set
versus that small data set might lead to very high
like changes in the model predictions. So the main
idea of multi fidelity linear regression in this
paper is that we're going to use multi fidelity
control variance to reduce the variance of this c,
x y estimate, which is then going to lower the
variance of the betas, which is going to lower
the variance of the predictions, which is going
to improve the learned model robustness. So.
Okay, so that's what's on this slide. Basically,
I'm saying I'm defining a multi fidelity estimator
of c, x, y, using this multi, multi failure Monte
Carlo form. So it's similar form to what's before.
I mean, those sums have gone away, because
the sums are kind of being written as these
matrix vector products. But you have this like M
sample estimate minus this n sample estimate. So
you should recognize that form something that
is different is that this is a D dimensional
vector that is being estimated. So whereas
Alpha was a like a scalar coefficient before,
here I've now replaced that with an A, which is
a matrix coefficient, so you can think of as kind
of like a gain. Just said that. And so with this
estimator, this multifidelity estimator of cxy,
then I have a multi fidelity estimator of beta,
which gives me a multi fidelity learned model
that uses those parameter estimates. So this
is kind of the main idea of the whole paper.
All right, so what I want to talk about
next is some of the analysis we're able
to do of this approach. Are there any
questions before I jump to that part?
Okay, okay, so the first key result is that this
multi fidelity linear regression estimator is
unbiased. So that was our estimator. And so the
first claim I'll make is that the expectation of
this estimator is the expectation of x, y1, which
appears in the true formulation for or in the true
formula for base star. And that's un biased.
I'll get to that question in a second. That's
unbiased for the same reason as multifamily Monte
Carlo, basically an expectation these two terms
are going to cancel because they're estimates
for the same statistic, just with a different
number of samples, because our estimator, beta
hat MF, is linear in C, hat, MF, then, in fact,
where our multi fidelity parameter estimate
for beta is unbiased with respect to the true
optimal parameter, it's followed from linearity.
And then finally, that means our predictions are
also unbiased. So that also follows from
linearity of the model and the parameters.
And this is significant, and it's basically saying
that by introducing this low fidelity data, like,
we're not changing the bias of the estimator.
So in that sense, the low fidelity estimator
does not have a corrupting influence on on the
learning even though we had, like, even though
we added this low fidelity data, Giselle, I'm
going to defer to that question until I talk
about a which will happen in like two slides.
Are there any questions about this unbiased bit?
All right, so thing I want to talk about is the
error. Because, you know, obviously the error of
a model sort of depends not only on the bias, but
also on the variance. So let's talk about what,
what is the variance of this multi fidelity
estimator? So remember, I was trying to
estimate x, y1, like, that's kind of what c x y is
trying to estimate. The mean of x y1. Is what c x
y is trying to estimate. So I'm going to define a
function g, which is just like f multiplied by the
features. So what I'm trying to do, essentially,
is estimate, like, do a multi fidelity estimate
of the mean of this function g now. And so
this is the sort of high fidelity function g,
and then I've got some correction terms based on
the low fidelity functions g, and so I can write
an expression for the variance of this estimator
in terms of covariances of G. So like you see that
like, so just as a reminder, G maps to like a
D dimensional vector, where d is the number of
features. And so I can define these gamma
like gamma one, one and gamma two, two and
gamma one two as being the covariance of like the
high fidelity with itself, covariance of the low
fidelity with itself, and like cross covariance
terms. And so we see that the variance of the
multi fidelity estimator definitely depends
on what this matrix A is, okay, and so that,
you know, starting to answer Jill's question, you
know, makes you wonder, okay, what's the best A?
So, just as a reminder, when I was just
estimating scalar means, like, the alpha,
which was a scalar coefficient, had an optimal
form that was the covariance of the f1 and f2
divided by the variance of f2 and so similarly,
we can show that to minimize the trace of the
covariance of this vector estimator, the
optimal a. Are that would minimize that
trace. The covariance is gamma one, two divided
by gamma two, like, basically divided by, but,
yeah, like, gamma two, two inverse, so it has
the same form. And so, you know, I mean that,
you know, kind of gives you some confidence that
maybe I did my proof correctly. And yeah, it does
reduce to this. And, like, the matrix, optimal
thing does reduce to the scalar. Optimal thing,
so that
would be the optimal way to choose
a star to minimize the variance of
the estimator. All right, so we
have a theorem basically saying,
okay with with the gammas defined the way
I've defined them, this choice is optimal in
the sense that it minimizes the trace of the
covariance of this multithreading estimator,
so it also minimizes the trace of the covariance
of the parameter estimates, and it therefore
minimizes the variance of the model predictions
like, you know, conditioned on the input.
So so
practical considerations, so I mentioned that
for, you know, standard multifid Monte Carlo,
just for scalar mean estimation, we have to
estimate these second order statistics of the
models to get the alpha star. And we usually do
that with pilot samples, and it works reasonably
well across a number of applications, but
just notice noting that for my regression,
setting up this optimal a star now depends
on these covariance matrices being estimated,
because I'm estimating a vector quantity, and in
general, that's going to be a harder estimation
problem than estimating sort of scalar statistics,
and might require a high number of pilot samples.
So the theoretical optimal a star may like
actually be quite expensive to compute. And
so since we're not sure we can get good estimates
of this theoretically optimal a star, we have some
practical alternatives. One is to say, Okay, what
if I restrict a to essentially be a scalar? So a
is going to be a scalar alpha times the identity,
then the optimal scalar coefficient has a form
that also may not surprise you. It like has, you
know, kind of similar resemblance to the optimal
a star. And so this is like, in this class of
A, this is the best way to choose alpha star,
trace of A gamma, one, two over trace
of gamma, two, two. Or alternatively,
if you don't even want to bother estimating
these traces, you could just say, Okay,
I'm just going to, just as a heuristic, use
this alpha star that came from mean estimation,
which you know is not optimal in any sense, but
what we find, we know works reasonably well. So
this slide essentially summarizes kind of
the three ways that we might choose that
scaling coefficient. And now I'll ask Giselle if
there's any sort of follow up questions on on a
or anyone Else, if anyone has questions.
Okay, glad to hear it.
Okay. So I talked about choosing a I haven't
really talked about choosing m and n, which is,
like, how to allocate the samples among, say,
maybe a fixed computational budget. And I'll
just say that we haven't really done this. I'm
saying, like, we could formulate a minimization
to do this, to say, like, what are the M and
N that are going to minimize this variance,
but it would be kind of complicated, and
would also depend on these estimates that we
that we think in practice might be quite
hard to get. So, you know, just practically,
maybe you already have data that's just like,
given to you. Like, here's some low fidelity data,
here's some high failure data. So like, probably
just want to use all of it, or as a heuristic use
the M and N that would come from the mfmc paper.
So there's, like I said, an analytical formula to
tell you how many samples to distribute to each
model. And so that's what I'm going to do in my
numerical experiments. This kind of heuristic
thing, all right, so just to summarize what
we were able to get out of the theoretical
analysis. So the first thing is the multi
fidelity approach is unbiased with respect to
the distribution of the high fidelity data. Okay,
so the low fidelity data do not have any kind
of corrupting influence. And something I want
to emphasize is that this is a kind of guarantee
that's possible in this multi fidelity control
variant setting that is not possible for what I
would think of as more ad hoc approaches, some
of which are based on transfer learning like you
don't have that guarantee that the low fidelity
data are not corrupting. We also show that if
you have variance reduction of the cxy estimator,
this is going to lead to reduced variance
in the coefficient estimators, and therefore
reduced variance in the model predictions. And
that's significant because it means that the
lower that the expected square error of the
learned model is going to be lower relative
to the high fidelity only training process. So we
have improvements in accuracy as well. So before
the last thing I have for you are some numerical
results. Are there questions at this point? Point.
Okay, all right. So
the first thing I have is an analytical example
in one dimension, because I can plot the models
and kind of show you how the variance looks. So
I just have a uniform random variable, Z. High
Fidelity function is an exponential function,
and the low fidelity function is an exponential
function that we've sort of moved around a little
bit, so it's a little bit off. In this case,
I pretend that the high fidelity model costs one
and the low fidelity model is a lot cheaper. So
one, 1000 times cheaper, and they have quite a
good correlation. This is like 97% correlated,
and we're going to fit a quartic model. So
yeah, here's the intercept, and then I've got,
you know, first, second, third and fourth order
features. So to ensure, like, fair comparisons,
we will say that the the cost of acquiring data
points is going to be fixed. And so we compare
standard, high fidelity only training. So just
filling up that whole budget with samples from
f1 with multi fidelity training, where I use that
mfmc model, like sample allocation algorithm to
determine the number of samples. And so this table
shows you, like, how many samples go to the high
fidelity model and the low fidelity model and the
multi fidelity approach. So for a budget of 10,
I use 80% of my budget on on high fidelity
samples, and kind of the remainder among M
there's a reason that, like, kind of a silly
reason, why this doesn't all add up to 10,
and that's something that I could fix, but I
just haven't. But anyway, so this is the number
of samples that are being used for different
budgets. And so I mean the main idea is, like,
you sacrifice a few high fidelity samples in order
to get a lot of low fidelity samples. And so the
reason I wanted to have this analytical
example is to basically show you the how,
the how these models varies. So the black line
on this plot is the best fit quartic function
to the exponential data. Or, you know, that's
that's taking exact expectations because we can,
because it's a simple example. So that's sort
of the optimum with respect to the underlying
distribution. These blue lines, which are plotted
with some transparency, show you different
realizations of the high fidelity trained model.
And this is with 100 samples, which is like a lot
of samples for a one dimensional example. And so
even with like 100 samples, you see there's quite
a lot of variation in the fitted quartic functions
for the high fidelity only data. And then in these
orange dashed lines, these are also plotted with
transparency, you see a lot narrower variation,
like they're much closer to that beta star.
Okay, so we're like, just kind of this is
the visual of showing you, like, how much more
robust the multi fidelity training approach is.
Okay? So I mean, I will walk you through this.
It's kind of a lot, okay, so now this is kind
of an exploration of the dependence of the
model on the hyper parameter, hyper parameters,
so like the choice of A and the choice of n and m,
which depend on those estimates of statistics. So,
as I mentioned before, we have, you know,
three different ways to choose that a like,
there's the optimal matrix coefficient, there's
like the optimal scalar coefficient, and then
there's kind of this heuristic that comes from
like, what you would do if you were estimating
the mean, and those three choices coefficient
depend on estimates of model statistics. So in
the left column, what I'm showing you is, okay,
I'm assuming I have the exact model statistics
right. So this is the case in which, like,
a star is optimal, and that's what you see,
the A star has the lowest variance. So this is
the trace of the covariance of that of the c, x,
y, this is the trace of the covariance of
the estimates, and this is for a fixed Z,
the variance of the model predictions. And
so yeah, that optimal alpha star coefficient
is like the best you can do if you truly know
the model statistics. And then these two scalar
things perform kind of similarly when you know
the optimal statistics, the exact statistics,
and then as I move to the right, I'm
estimating these optimal statistics, as
well as the optimal and as well as the heuristic.
And m with 100 pilot samples, which is, you know,
probably more than is realistic, but, and then
10 pilot samples, so that's really quite few,
and then you see, okay, like when you have just
10 pilot samples, okay, theoretically, the matrix
coefficient would be optimal. But in fact, it's
self optimal because you have poor statistics
that you're basing that that coefficient on.
But despite the, you know, the fact that there.
Some sensitivity to estimating the statistics,
we see consistently that these multi fidelity
strategies have lower variance in the predictions
than the high fidelity only of the same cost.
Okay, so that was an analytical example,
and now I have a PDE model problem. This
is a convection diffusion reaction, you
know, model in a two dimensional domain,
and it's like a one step chemistry model. And
so I have five input parameters which this A,
is not the same as the matrix A, this is now the
Arrhenius reaction. A, the activation energy,
E, temperature of the inflow, and like initial
temperature at the wall. And then fee is like a
fuel oxidizer ratio. So these are five parameters.
The output I want to predict is the maximum
temperature in the chamber at steady state. And
my high fidelity data then comes from like a 2d
Finite Difference simulation where the cost is 1.9
and that's actually in seconds, so 1.9 seconds.
And then I have low fidelity data that comes from
a pod dime model, and that has a cost of like
six thousandths of a second. And in this case, we
have a 95% correlation between the models. So this
is still pretty highly correlated. Okay, so here
I'm showing you that for this example. So also
fitting a quartic model, but to five inputs,
so there's, like, I think, like 25 features,
or something like that here, though, the main
thing to highlight is that when I'm estimating,
so, like, I have, like, a ton of samples just
stored. And so if I've got high sample estimates,
like the A star, the matrix optimal coefficient
does do better, as it should in theory. But then
when I have to estimate those statistics, those
covariance matrices, to choose the a star, alpha
star and alpha mean, the A star is not on this
plot, because it's like 10 to the I don't know,
like 20, okay, so it's just so bad that you
wouldn't want to do that, because it's you just
don't have good estimates for those covariance
matrices. However, the optimal matrix coefficient,
alpha star, does do much better. And so that's
kind of our general recommendation in the
paper. This is probably the thing to go with in
practical settings. And again, like, you know,
consistently we see that, like, when you do that,
like, you get a lower variance in the predictions
for multi fidelity training than with high
fidelity training of the same cost. And then here,
I just want to show you how that translates to
improvement in the prediction error or in the
generalization error. So here I've just, you
know, drawn some samples from the distribution
that are from that are not seen in training. And
this dotted black line is kind of the optimal
prediction error, like computed optimal computed
with a ton of samples. Basically, it's like a very
high sample reference. So that's the best we could
do. And then with high fidelity only, I'm showing
you here's kind of the mean over a bunch of
realizations of training, and then I've got, like,
the plus minus one standard deviation and shaded.
And that's over just a bunch of realizations of
training on like, different independent training
sets. And that's for high fidelity in blue,
and then low fidelity and orange. So here you
really see the fact that we're lowering the
variance of those predictions is significantly
lowering the average prediction error,
or average generalization error, and also
narrowing, like, kind of how wide that range
is. So it's making it robust and it's making it
more accurate. It's kind of the key takeaway,
and that effect is particularly pronounced in this
low budget regime, right? So like, when, when,
when data is scarce, that's where you're really
seeing, like, you know, significant gains. So
that brings me kind of to the end of things.
So here's a QR code for the archive paper,
and to just to summarize, so we have a new multi
fidelity linear regression method that combines
high and low fidelity data during model training.
The multi fidelity learned models are unbiased and
they have lower expected square error than
standard training. But we do have a lot of
open questions. Like, you know, someone was,
I think Giselle, was asking about like, can we
handle different inputs? Not right now, but we're
thinking about it. I also presented this like,
entirely for vector for scalar predictions, like
scalar outputs. And there are some interesting
questions about what you would do if you are
predicting vector outputs. There's also questions
about like, how would you extend this to non
linear regression, which we're working on? And
have some ideas. There's, like, actually many ways
you could think about extending about extending it
to non linear regression, as well as additional
analytical questions, in particular, like multi
fidelity. Monte Carlo has a lot of literature
on, like, how to select models to guarantee that
they're going to be useful, and that's kind
of something we could also do here, but have
not gotten around to yet. So. So thank you for
your attention, and I'm happy to take questions.
All right, thank you so much for the wonderful
talk. We have a question. Gizelle asked,
how the correlation between the models
affect the performance. What is the minimum
correlations you'd recommend between
the models for usable results? Yeah,
that is a great question. And I will say we have
not done that analysis for the regression setting,
but a lot of that analysis has been done for the
just the Monte Carlo setting, which is different,
okay, and so from the Monte Carlo setting, some of
the things we learned is it's, you know, it's not
like that. There's a cut off for the correlation,
but there's a cut off for the correlation with
respect to how much the like, how high the cost
ratio is. So when I was doing multifidelity Monte
Carlo for like, just uncertainty quantification
for a telescope model, we found we we like used
models with correlation as low as, like, 38% with
significant cost reduction. It was like a 10,
like, you know, 10 or, sorry, 10 to the six,
like six orders of magnitude cost reduction.
And then you can show that that still leads
to variance reduction. So it's really like,
the worse the model is, the cheaper it has
to be to be useful. Um, but emphasizing that,
that's what we've been able to show, both
numerically and theoretically for estimating
means, and that estimating parameters of linear
regression does complicate things a little
bit. Well, I have a question.
So in your second examples,
your lower fidelity model was the
PODD, V, I am, and I know some other,
you know, researcher who's working on
the multi fidelity settings. They also
add the cost of the training the poddin
model. I'm guessing you haven't included
that. No, I haven't. Right now I'm just
saying like, I'm treating those, those models,
as kind of like oracles that we have, and then the
question is, like, how would you use the data that
arises from that? But I mean, I think it's a good
question. I know that. You know, there are other
people working on these sort of context aware
approaches, where you're kind of, like, taking
into account how much, yeah, like, how much effort
it takes to just get the low fidelity source. So
those are connecting those that body of literature
to, this is definitely an area of interest.
Thank you. Next question is by Boris. Boris,
you're you're here. I can also ask
you the person, okay, Elizabeth,
maybe I think I probably missed this. You're
optimally assigning these, these MS and N's right?
I am heuristically assigning the M's and N's
based on the optimal model management approach
for mean estimation. I briefly touched on this
that, like you could try to formulate a problem
that optimally assigns the M's and N's for the
linear regression thing, but it would depend on
so many statistic estimates that we don't think
we can get well in practical settings, that we
think that a heuristic is likely to be, you know,
practically useful, okay? Or practically useful?
Yeah, thank you. Nice talk. All right. The
next question is by Kevin, thanks for the
great talk. The PD example doesn't, didn't seem
to be a linear regression problem. Or maybe,
yeah, I think I was not, maybe as as clear and
explicit about that as I should have been. So
we are fitting a quartic model to these five
parameters. So like, the features x of z are like,
you know, like various for, you know,
constant and first through fourth order
polynomial terms of these five model, five
parameters that are being fit. So, yeah, so
now this is still apply, okay, all right. Next
question is by Eric Chang earlier, I think you
mentioned something about the low fidelity model
being based on some transfer learning approach,
possibly breaking the Yeah, bias estimator.
Could you expand that? Yeah, yeah. Let
me so let me say that, like, I think there's
a lot of interest in multi fidelity learning
approaches and people. I mean, there's so many
different ways you could do you could combine
high and low fidelity data. So I've seen things
where it's like, you have two neural networks,
and one trains on high fidelity data, one trains
on low fidelity data, and then you add them
together somehow. Or I've seen things where you
like string, like, string, like, you know, five
different neural networks together, and some of
them map between the high and low fidelity data,
and some of them are just for the high fidelity
data, and some are just for the low fidelity data.
And I've seen things where it's like, one neural
network, or, I mean, one model, and you just train
on the low fidelity data, and then you just at
the end, you throw in the high fidelity data,
just to kind of update things. So there's many
ways you could do this. Um. Um, and the point I
was trying to make is that we're doing it in a
way that's based on the multi fidelity control
variant literature, which has a lot of theory,
including this guarantee of unbiasedness. And that
is something I have not seen for these other
approaches that I was just describing. Like,
you know, if you just throw in the high fidelity
data at the end, you don't get that kind of
guarantee of unbiasedness like so, I mean, that's
not to say that there couldn't exist a guarantee
if you were careful about it, just that I
haven't seen that in that literature. And
so this is something that I think is an advantage
of this approach based on multi fidelity control
variants. All right. Thank you. Next
question is by Zachary, yes, the can
you use more than one low fidelity model? Yes.
So this extends very easily to more than one
low fidelity model. And you just, kind of,
you end up adding like more terms of the same kind
like, more like. So you'd have like a second term
with like your f3 and another term with your
f4 and then in these variants that I mentioned,
the generalized approximate control variants, as
well as like the ML blue estimators that are like,
sort of even more general ways of combining those
models. And I will say they're more general,
and they get greater variance reduction under
the assumption that you kind of have those
exact statistics. So it's kind of unclear in
practice, like how well you do if you don't
have great Statistics estimates, but there's
lots of ways to to to add other models in
Awesome. Well, let me ask this question up
so, so you like the unbiased model? I can see,
yeah, in some sense that's Can, can? It can be
also viewed as a modeling bias, right? I mean,
you have a mean and bias, and you know to make
it unbiased, you, you, you go another level, and
then for you, you, you apply the multi covariate
method on that. So I see that like hierarchical,
you know, modeling approach, you start with the
mean and second order statistics, third order,
fourth order statistics, and so on and on to
to make the bias model to unbiased. Oh, if you
maybe you have a different view on that. Yeah, I
That's not how I would describe it, like I
would say, you know, this approach is really
about reducing the variance of estimators
of the of the learned model parameters,
and we have an approach where we use an unbiased
estimator for the model parameters, so that when
we combine them in the multi fidelity sense, the
multi fidelity estimator also remains unbiased
if and we're not really using like, higher order
like. The only higher order statistics that kind
of enter into into the model are the second order
statistics, which are just used for choosing hyper
parameters of the method. There's, like, no third
order or fourth order statistics in this method,
yeah, if you don't use the
estimates, but at the end,
in practical sense, you're using estimates, yeah,
in the practical sense, we are using
estimates of the second order statistics,
but second order, fourth order
statistics don't enter anywhere,
yeah, yeah. So if I rephrase my question,
since we are using the estimate,
there will be another bias times
which we ignore. The estimates,
the guarantees of the optimality, of
the variance reduction, are, you know,
sort of approximate guarantees. But
in fact, the unbiasedness does not
depend on those things. So no matter
what, like, the unbiasedness is there,
even if we estimate statistics, okay, and
that's just from the form of the estimator.
Okay, thank you. Elizabeth, is there any
other question? Wow, that's a punctual 11am
we started punctually at 10am and looks like we
are ending punctual, punctually at 11am excellent.
Gold Star. Gold Star, yes,
all right, if there has no further questions,
let's thank our speaker Elizabeth
for the wonderful talk. Elizabeth,
you're the great teacher. I can see like
students will love to take your classes. I
appreciate that. I hope they
do. Thank you for having me. All
right, thank you. Thank you, Elizabeth. All right.
That ends our seminar today. Let
me stop the record button. You.
Well, I have.